Matt: Hi YouTube, this is Matt from British
council.
I've just been in the BBC debate on the financial
crisis.
It's been very interesting, very exciting,
quite a tough discussion.
But one thing that’s on my mind after this
discussion, after hearing this discussion
is that several of the people on stage said
that the current financial crisis is not due
to individuals or companies doing something
wrong.
It's actually a systemic thing.
So it's the system that is wrong.
Now what I'm wondering is, once we've solved
the crisis -- touch wood -- and things go
well again.
I wonder if they're also going to say well
it's not because of us that we're making so
much money, it's because of the system.
So I think that the big trick out there is
that there is huge lack of taking any responsibility.
We can't probably make the banks and companies
responsible for everything now that's gone
wrong, but If they don't take any responsibility,
how are we going to trust you again.
Thank you very much.